what's up you guys my name is Matt
you're watching Kotex - toriel's and I
wanted to talk a little bit today about
how to actually land a job now this is a
somewhat in contrast to one of my videos
getting the most or close to the most
views on my channel about landing a job
and I just want to hash out three
concepts that you can use to basically
get any job you want in the world so if
you've got time to hear this out
it could do you a lot of good it's just
something I've noticed I'm just a
regular guy I'm not a guru people seem
to call me coach Jesus or guilfoyle or
something I don't know whatever my name
is Matt I just a computer scientists
programmer that I don't know figured out
a lot of stuff I guess so alright we'll
get into it the first thing the very
first thing okay so we want to unpack
this a little bit think when someone is
looking to hire another person they want
someone that can get the job done that's
that's always number one no matter what
their scenario your scenario aside from
all the stuff going on them on in the
world they have something that needs
done they may have a bunch of things
that need done and they need someone
that can do it it's really that simple
so the point here is to be a try-hard
and that's just a simplified way of
saying do everything in your power to
better yourself to be good at whatever
this Duty is and to take care of it now
this really needs to be tempered with
these other two points because as you
may have noticed most try-hards well
they're not always easy to work with so
my second point here is while being a
try-hard don't frustrate yourself or at
least try not to sure you're bound to
get
point we're only human but the point
here is try not to if you've noticed
yourself getting frustrated you need to
accept that and recognize it and it will
help you better move on and this leads
me into my second point don't be
annoying one of the big reasons people
don't get hired or get let go it's
because they're annoying and I say it
just simply don't be annoying because
that's another all-encompassing way
phrase the lack of a better word that
basically says you need to take care of
yourself and you need to be respectful
of people around you this is just you
know there's so much here it's a lot
about self-improvement again but this
isn't necessarily directly related to
the duties of the job this is more about
can you properly greet people can can
you send an email in a timely manner
that is not a bunch of typos garbage and
can you get ready in the morning and
take care of your appearance at least
appropriately you know the usual stuff
can you work with others when they ask
you questions even if they annoy you can
you be honest when you're presented with
something that you don't necessarily
have to be honest on or about people do
notice these things so this also helps
you weed out things that won't work for
you because you will notice some in some
organizations some jobs whatever it may
be there's this I will say a small
percentage of them overall that are not
good jobs and we all recognize this it's
just a wall of odds now some people
might think this is a really high number
because they've had a lot of bad
experiences but I well it's hard to say
it really just really depends on you and
your experience but if you're trying
hard and you're being very respectful I
think there's about a 98% chance
that you're gonna have a good experience
so you've got like maybe a 2% odds of
getting a job that is just there's
nothing good to say about it
and if it is that type of job you know
you shouldn't take it to begin with
there's plenty of others and if you are
this special person that actually tries
hard and can get stuff done no matter
your degree no matter your previous
previous training if you can just say
look I don't know but I would love to
learn I'll look it up
if your employer says hey look I need
you to find the area of this awkward
shaped building and figure out something
you might say whoa that's a lot of
complicated stuff no but you don't say
that you said okay I'll get right on
that
and you start trying you take
measurements you do the calculations if
you don't live the math look up the map
it's that's middle school algebra from
what I remember but to be perfectly
honest I might not even remember all the
formulas so I would look them up just to
double-check and be sure so that's just
a new example
oddly specific example let me get to my
third point understand that nobody
expects you to be perfect you are going
to make mistakes but if you're trying
and you're being honest and you're not
being annoying they will see that and
they and a mistake here and there will
be glazed over like it's nothing
because they'll think oh I'm at messed
this up but he's working on it I think
he's got it and I'll have it another day
and they'll be like so why would I ever
get rid of this person you know it's
like well that would be such a pain okay
for the most part most employers care
about you and they want you to do well
so they don't want to just fire you but
even if they had complete disregard for
your well-being and only
the tasks done they would still have to
be faced with okay I've got fire this
person I've got to interview others I
gotta find someone that I'll accept the
job I gotta find someone that could pick
up the duties
it's a giant pain in the butt to get a
new employee to replace an old employee
employee so if you're if you're making a
little mistake here and there but your
overall doing excellent and figuring
stuff out they won't care at all oh I
say it all but you know so that's my
advice
that's my experience I hope this helps I
am kind of in a situation where in a way
I feel like I could potentially get
about any job in the world that I wanted
and I say that just knowing these three
simple things be a try-hard don't be
annoying and understand that people
don't expect you to be perfect thank you
for watching my video
he's have you guys stay safe and good
luck and all your future endeavors Matt
out